bonjour arnaud de thézac merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france on vient donc de le voir
l'armée nationale libyenne fait partir
300 combattants étrangers des zones
contrôlées par le maréchal haftar dans
l'est libyen une mesure je cite à la
demande de la france quelle lecture
faites-vous de cette information
alors si on veut pas on ne peut pas
surtout pas faire une lecture au premier
degré
les les intérêts si vous voulez en jeu
remonte à l'époque obama il faut pas
l'oublier qui a mis en place les
printemps arabes qui était en réalité
une manière de faire prendre le pouvoir
à la confrérie des frères musulmans sur
l'ensemble du bassin méditerranéen
et puis aujourd'hui les choses ont après
dix ans donc ça a été vraiment une
catastrophe par rapport aux populations
civiles en particulier mais les choses
ont changé donc les voisins ont changé
la tunisie a changé le gouvernement
actuellement est un gouvernement
d'exception les membres du gouvernement
et ceux des frères musulmans sont partis
au maroc c'est la même chose l'algérie
se dote de pouvoirs dont françois
extérieur l'egypte évidemment renverser
les frères musulmans etc donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui les seuls frères
musulmans qui restent actifs sont en
libye soutenue par la turquie il ya un
élément important à comprendre
autour de ce indépendamment des des
rêves de puissance ottomane de
résurrection de la puissance et au mal
il ya quelque chose qui est rarement
cités mais qui est l'exploitation du gaz
en méditerranée pour faire simple il y à
un accord depuis 2010 neuf qui n'a pas
été reconnue par les instances
internationales qui n'a pas été acceptée
par l'onu comme instruments
internationaux mais peu importe il ya un
accord qui existe entre la libye d'avant
le processus électoral peut-être 2019 et
la turquie et qui fait une sorte de
fonds de souveraineté maritime
directement entre la turquie la libye
imaginer une sorte de grand points en
diagonale dans la méditerranée au sud de
la glace et la grèce évidemment ni
n'entend pas de cette oreille puisque un
bassin économique ça me parlait de la
turquie
recep tayyip erdogan le président turc
n'est pas présent pour cette conférence
sur la libye à paris alors qu'il ya par
exemple angela merkel la chancelière
allemande ou mario draghi le premier
ministre italien qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre alors de cette conférence sur
paris avec les forces en plus envie de
dire les personnalités présentes alors
dit doug est une chose c'est que même si
lui même n'est pas là il ya des gens qui
représentent ses intérêts au sein du
pardon sans voir un message quand même
alors c'est pas sûr parce qu'on dit
qu'il ya dit qu'il a des ennuis de santé
donc voyez je vous donne une information
mais apparemment il n'y a pas forcément
que des raisons politiques à son absence
c'est ça reste un point qu'il faudra
vérifier mais qui pourra qui pourrait se
vérifier mais effectivement il aurait pu
le faire au moins une intervention par
skype et autres enfin en tout cas ce en
présence mais si vous voulez il ya
l'intérêt de la turquie qui est là la
turquie joue un scellé une base navale à
mistrata prendre le contrôle du port de
misrata dont des accords préalables du
temps de sarkozy en avait donné
l'exploitation en tout cas le la
construction ou bolloré en france mais
ça c'est une histoire passée non le
poids stratégique aujourd'hui
économique si vous voulez aux gars du
pétrole mais ça c'est un aspect c'est
assez simple à comprendre c'est le gaz
c'est un c'est un partage si vous voulez
des ressources gazières entre la turquie
et l'egypte donc les
l'egypte a passé un an après cet accord
entre la turquie et la libye
l'egypte a passé un accord avec la grèce
évidemment qui qui fait fi de cette
prétention illicites d'ailleurs de la
turquie à fort et du gaz à l'ouest de
chypre pour faire simple et au sud de la
gare donc là un élément économique très
important qui est la ressource gazière
qui non encore exploitées n'ai testé
numéro numéro oui dans les haies les i
heard on parle de six mois et puis
numéro deux il y à un autre élément
important qui est un élément on va dire
idéologique dans la mesure où
vous avez donc la mouvance des frères
musulmans qui avaient le vent pour peter
groupama il faut se souvenir que byden a
été partie prenante dans cette opération
et qu'il est aujourd'hui président des
états unis il ya des restes
et puis vous avez tous les toutous les
tous des pétromonarchies bien sûr arabie
saoudite les émirats et bien sûr
l'egypte et puis dès maintenant le maroc
qui s'en débarrassaient tunisie
également tous ces gens là qui ne
veulent pas des frères musulmans pour
des raisons idéologiques donc vous avez
une deuxième couche idéologique très
importante qui ait ce bras de fer si
vous voulez contrôler la mouvance des
frères musulmans et l'amour des antilles
frères musulmans donc là c'est l'avenir
d'un dogan en fait qui se joue à paris
est ce que on est ce que la france elle
même à une puissance une force
suffisante pour
arbitrer non elle est manifestement
alliés des opposants à la turquie ce qui
ne va pas forcément être
bien bien ressenti par les turcs et qui
risque de créer des conflits
plus important vol imagine entre la
france elle est dernière question
rapidement noté zac en marge de cette
conférence sur la libye il ya une
rencontre attendue entre sergueï lavrov
et jean yves le drian les chefs des
diplomaties russe et français qu'est ce
qui va ressortir selon vous de ce face à
face sachant qu'il ya également sergueï
choïgou et florence parly un ministre
des armées alors en jeu aussi alors ça
c'est effectivement c'est pas du tout du
tout neutre que le bras armé
de la puissance militaire russe qui est
largement supérieur à la puissance
française en termes de
l'opérationnalité conventionnelles en
tout cas même si on nuclear c'est un
sujet on n'abandonnera pas mme et donc
c'est pas du tout neutre et ça s'inscrit
dans un
tir à côté ce qui est beaucoup plus
large à cette fois ci puisque
la france
doit être clair sur ses alliances il ya
les opérations comme depuis depuis des
années qui vise à démanteler la russie à
affaiblir la france est et de ce côté là
est-ce qu'elle va changer ce qu'on peut
en attendre ces deux choses soit on va
voir 'l'annonce d'un bouleversement
d'alliance
venant de le drian j'en doute un petit
peu soi où on est en train de négocier
on va dire des zones de deux
qui seront exclues de théâtre
d'opérations donc ce sont des ce sont
des discussions extrêmement compliqué il
est si vous voulez globalement sur toute
cette histoire d'amitié renée et un
point commun qui est important c'est que
aucune communication réelle au peuple et
de reddition de comptes si vous voulez à
la représentation nationale sur ce qui
est en train de se passer il ya des on
est à la veille de les frictions
militaires majeures
tous les ingrédients sont réunis et la
france n'est pas au courant de ce qui se
passe rien et je pense que là il ya
quand même un petit point très négatif
par rapport au gouvernement français qui
qui fait cavalier seul par rapport à par
rapport à la population française et au
dos jean est et à l'avenir de la france
qui est en train de se décider en ce
moment merci arnaud de thézac d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes géopolitologue et chargé de
cours à l'université de genève